Disney's hit musical Encanto is loaded with
easter eggs and references including Frozen,
Tangled, and Hercules, plus secret clues that
predict the movie's ending.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the top 50 things
you missed and details to look out for in
Encanto.
Spoilers ahead, so take care.
This video's sponsored by Omaze.
For a chance to win a multi-million-dollar
dream house in LA, go to Omaze.com/Flicks
To highlight the ambiguity and mystery around
Bruno's character, the filmmakers used a lot
of green when he's on screen, so when he pops
up for the first time in "We Don't Talk About
Bruno", the lighting of the scene instantly
changes to green.
And Mirabel's link to him is hinted at via
her green-coloured glasses and skirt as well
as her door and room, foreshadowing the fact
she'll uncover the truth and end the family's
silence about her missing uncle.
And there's a clue to Bruno's power to see
the future when Mirabel goes into his tower,
the entrance to which is shaped like an hourglass.
Hourglasses are used to measure time, so it's
fitting the film often uses them, for instance
on Bruno's door and his poncho, as a sign
of his ability to see through the sands of
time and into the future.
Luisa's song "Surface Pressure" is a lot of
fun with many great visuals and hilarious
dancing donkeys, which remind me of the singing
reindeers in Kristoff's Frozen 2 song.
As well as featuring a reference to the Titanic,
the song also includes a shout-out to the
myth of Hercules which Disney adapted for
its own animated movie when Luisa fights the
three-headed hound Cerberus.
A cool bonus detail you might have missed
is the crowd of donkey spectators in the background
watching her in the arena.
Also, the split in the ground beneath Luisa
foreshadows the cracks that later appear in
the house and also how the mountains behind
the casita split in two as the house begins
to fall apart.
The filmmakers chose pastel and pink colours
for Isabela's clothes and room to give her
a princess vibe to go with her reputation
of a Señorita Perfecta.
Did someone say flowers?
Please, don't clap.
But after she breaks out of that unwanted
role, Isabela sheds that image, opting for
more vibrant colours instead.
At the start of the movie, Antonio's outfit
is white to show that he hasn't got his abilities
yet;
he's a blank-slate, powers-wise.
However, afterwards, his clothes become more
colourful and feature some of the creatures
he can communicate with.
The outfits worn by all the family are also
colour-coordinated to reflect the different
branches of the Madrigal family tree.
Mirabel, her sisters and parents are dressed
in cool tones:
blues, purples, and greens;
while Pepa, her husband and kids are dressed
in warmer tones, such as oranges, yellows,
and reds.
There's a fun moment in the first song, "The
Family Madrigal", when the three village kids
demand to know all the family's powers:
Just tell us what everyone can do!
And that's why coffee's for grown-ups!
It's more than just an amusing joke though,
because in Colombia it's not uncommon for
kids to drink coffee, though it's generally
not very strong.
After Antonio gets his gift and opens the
door to its magical world, the villagers are
invited inside and as the excitable kids enter,
one of them exclaims "it's bigger on the inside",
a hat-tip to Doctor Who and what people often
say when they first enter the TARDIS.
The expansive area behind each door reflects
each character's magical power and personality
and is inspired by magical realism.
In fact, there's a special tribute in Encanto
to Colombian author Gabriel García Márquez,
known for the magical realism in his stories.
The yellow butterflies in the film are a homage
to the ones that appear in one of his best-known
novels, 100 Years of Solitude.
There's also a butterfly motif on Abuela's
enchanted candle and, when the casita is first
created, butterflies magically appear.
A yellow butterfly also appears when Bruno
creates a new vision for Mirabel and a swarm
of them form when Mirabel and Abuela reconcile
by the river.
There are also numerous butterflies hidden
in the background of the movie, from Mirabel's
accordion, to the casita's door knocker, to
the wallpaper inside Mirabel's room, and butterfly
patterns in the walls of the house.
Abuela also has one on a brooch she wears
and Mirabel has many on her outfit.
One of the filmmakers has said that the butterflies'
"wings represent a bit of magic that is directly
linked to the candle that originally brought
the miracle to the family."
More generally as well, butterflies often
symbolise transformation, freedom, and new
beginnings, which also fits the story of the
Madrigal family and their home.
There's a sneaky Frozen easter egg in Encanto,
but just before I reveal that, if you'd like
a magical dream house of your own, thanks
to our sponsor Omaze you have the chance to
win this luxurious 5-bedroom, 6-bathroom house
in LA with in-home movie theater, heated pool,
bar, sports court, and home gym.
This 4.3 million-dollar home in the City of
Angels is among the latest one-of-a-kind prizes
that Omaze gives away while donating money
to chosen charities across the world,
and it comes complete with an open-concept
living room and kitchen perfect for entertaining
friends and family, plus LA's beaches and
vibrant nightlife are just minutes away.
For your chance to win this stunning house
or three million dollars in cash, go to Omaze.com/Flicks
to donate and support Rebuilding Together,
a charity devoted to repairing the homes of
veterans, people with disabilities, and low-income
families.
The charity's long-term projects include revitalizing
entire neighborhoods by improving parks, schools,
community centers, and non-profit facilities.
And Rebuilding Together is also instrumental
in recovery efforts after natural disasters.
So for your chance to win this dream house
and support a great cause, go to Omaze.com/Flicks
to donate.
When Bruno returns to the family in the song
"All of You" he raps a little, then gives
a nice tribute to Elsa's iconic "Let It Go"
moment in Frozen as he sings "let it snow,
let it go" and showers himself with salt to
mimic snow falling.
This one might be a little stretch but I got
some Rapunzel vibes from Isabela whenever
she swung around on vines created from her
magical gift, similar to how Rapunzel would
swing around on her magical hair in Tangled.
Mirabel's mother Julieta has the special power
to heal physical ailments with her food.
You just healed my hand with an arepa con
queso.
And this is very tricky to spot, but in her
kitchen there are some books, one of which
is titled "Cerveza para el dolor de cabeza"
which in English means "Beer for headaches".
The deliberately DIY, customised look of Mirabel's
outfit reflects her personality and desperate
desire to be noticed among a family of super-gifted
individuals.
As well as her own name and picture, her highly
embroidered skirt, blouse, and bag include
shout-outs to her loved ones.
For Abuela, there's a candle;
for Pepa, a rainbow as well as a sun and rain
cloud;
various flowers for her sister Isabela;
an arm holding up a weight, for her sister
Luisa;
a variety of animals such as snakes and capybaras
for cousin Antonio, and a chameleon for Camilo.
And there's even a note that she loves her
family in there.
As for Mirabel's glasses, according to the
film team, they're part of the storytelling
as a key theme of the movie is perception
and perspective and the role it plays in family
dynamics,
in other words, as one of the production designers
says, it's about 'how two people can view
the same situation completely differently,
and how those different points of view can
affect their relationship.'
On top of that, Mirabel's whole look including
her glasses meant a lot to actress Stephanie
Beatriz who also wore glasses growing up and
sees a lot of herself in the character, so
much so that she started crying the first
time she saw Mirabel brought to life.
When Lin-Manuel Miranda sat down to write
"The Family Madrigal", he was especially inspired
by the much-loved opening number from Beauty
And The Beast, 'Belle'.
Just like 'Belle', 'Family Madrigal' gives
us a ton of information in a relatively short
amount of time.
And also just as the first song in Beauty
And The Beast presents its main characters
and townsfolk, giving us insight into their
roles in the movie, so too Encanto's opening
number introduces us to three generations
of the Madrigal family, and also shows us
how they interact with people in their village.
Each character's magical gift is also reflected
in their clothing, and you can catch a lot
more details about the characters and their
development in The Art of Encanto book.
Isabela's flower power is shown through her
dress which is layered to give the feel of
petals while Colombia's national flower, the
orchid, is embroidered around her neckline.
Luisa's outfit features weights, representing
her super-strength.
Also, look out for raindrops on their aunt
Pepa's dress, as well as lightning bolts,
and her little sun earrings, all of which
represent her ability to control the weather
with her emotions.
Julieta has lots of herbs in her clothes which
are a nod to her power of healing through
her cooking.
And although her husband Agustín doesn't
have any powers of his own to illustrate on
his outfit, he does have little hat-tips to
his three daughters,
with a flower from Isabela in his lapel, and
one sock patterned with barbells for Luisa,
and the other embroidered with many things
including butterflies for Mirabel.
As for Pepa's husband Félix, according to
the filmmakers, the triangles and other geometric
shapes on his outfit represent his stability
and support for his family.
And his gifted son Camilo's clothes feature
chameleons on his poncho and sandals, which
fits his shape-shifting powers!
As the head of the Madrigal family, Abuela's
room is at the centre of the house, and opposite
hers is Mirabel's room, which highlights their
connection and foreshadows the end of the
movie, as both women are central to the creation
of the casita.
But the position of the rooms also points
to their opposite opinions as well, with Abuela
desperately trying to hold to the past and
how things have been, while Mirabel sees things
must change for a better future for everyone.
Actor Alan Tudyk voices the Toucan in the
movie,
Uh, huh.
I understand you.
and after also lending his voice to animations
including the Wreck-It Ralph movies
Hello, my royal subjects!
Big Hero 6
I love that robot!
Frozen
The Duke of Weaseltown.
Weselton!
Zootopia
It's Weaselton!
Duke Weaselton!
Moana
And Raya and the Last Dragon
He's fast becoming Disney's equivalent to
Pixar's good-luck charm John Ratzenberger.
And when I was looking out for hidden Mickeys,
I wondered whether this cactus Isabela creates
could be one.
Let me know what you think and if you spotted
any others!
So who are your favourite characters in Encanto?
And did you notice any other easter eggs?
Tell me in the comments below.
Thanks to Omaze for sponsoring this video.
Go to Omaze.com/Flicks for a chance to win
this incredible LA dream house.
Don't forget to like and subscribe if you
enjoyed this video.
And you can tap left for my next Disney video
including all the deleted scenes from Raya
and the Last Dragon.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!